in this episode of cloud performance
atlas I help some gaming nomads find
their way back to performance should we
have stopped to ask for directions stay
tuned to find out nomads socialite was a
new geolocation game where players
traveled all around the world to rack up
points catch the latest in urban events
and meet a whole community all at the
same time the game has been a hit but
their event producers noticed that the
analytic system which was powered by
datastore started to slow significantly
when updating see anytime you're trying
to store analytics data in datastore I
can tell you the problem without even
checking contention
simply put datastore contention occurs
when a single entity or entity group is
updated too rapidly once contention gets
high enough datastore will queue
concurrent requests to wait their turn
but if the number of edits on an entity
is too high things will eventually slow
down as the requests stack up until
timeout errors are thrown specifically
we see this most often when using
datastore for things like counting the
number of views to a page on your site
or in the case of Nomad socialites
updating the analytics data for an event
meant keeping a running count of the
number of users logged in and all of
their related data sets now when this
happens there's lots of ways to address
it but the simplest might be sharding
sharding effectively duplicates an
entity and uses a version of manual load
balancing to write updates to the clones
instead of all to the same item the
result is that each clone is partially
updated with respect to your data set
when you read from the sharded set you
fetch all copies and sum them together
on the client you'll end up with the
same results but with less contention to
show the performance difference we wrote
a small test using the artillery
framework in order to simulate their
user base the graph here shows pretty
much what we expected our sharded
version outperforms its regular
counterpart since sharding distributes
the work across more entities the
contention is lower thus performance is
better if you're interested in how to
set up sharding or some other options in
case sharding doesn't suit your needs
check out the article linked in the
description below and don't forget to
check out the rest of the cloud
performance Atlas content because when
it comes to performance every
millisecond counts